well that clearly wasn't supposed to be
there there's a common phrase that goes
there's no such thing as a perfect movie
this also applies to our beloved disney
films regardless of how much effort and
care is put into them sometimes the
creative team doesn't catch their own
blunders we're looking at some of those
mistakes made in disney flicks
okay can i just say something crazy
i love crazy as anna and hans dance in
front of the lighthouse in the love is
an open door sequence the lighthouse
casts a shadow of them onto a nearby
ship what you may not have noticed is
that their shadows seem to be hovering
in midair while we wouldn't put it past
disney to inject some of their magic in
a scene like this the two are clearly
not floating when they're on screen did
it seem magical as a young raya and
namari share a meal and bond in the
opening of raya and the last dragon a
bowl of food can be seen lying down in
front of raya though just a few seconds
later the bull has somehow moved to
behind raya either this is some fang
trickery or just a minor slip up who's
to say for sure
i made a mistake
i trusted someone i shouldn't have
your eyes may have been too misty to
catch this goof in the climax of luca as
the judge inspects luca and alberto's
bike at the finish line it's located
right smack dab in the middle moments
later in the shot where luca's parents
rushed to him the bike has magically
moved over to the far edge of the finish
line now how did that get there you
raised her little tail off and kicked so
much human butt and i'm so proud of you
as the infant moana walks towards the
magical ocean there's a lot of odd
little mishaps happening around her
whether or not it was intentional by the
animators is up for debate her footsteps
in the sand disappear in each shot while
the palm tree leaf that she interacts
with also disappears even the fish who
for a moment plops out of the water
doesn't leave an impact when he's put
back in his place oh there you are moana
what are you doing you scared me
i know i know you may have been too
caught up in idina menzel's incredible
singing voice to notice this mistake in
frozen's iconic let it go scene as elsa
creates her icy castle you'll notice
that she undoes her braided hair but
there's something even weirder going on
you'll notice that elsa's braid
literally passes through her arm like a
ghost disobeying the laws of physics
whoa elsa you look
different
in the scene where ian and barley are
pulled over by officer bronco while
trying to get across the bridge you'll
notice that the officer takes off his
shades but just a few moments later the
shade seemed to have disappeared from
his hands entirely and are now nowhere
to be found i'm giving you to the count
of three
okay we'll go as the charming and
stubborn demigod maui steals te fiti's
heart in the pulse-pounding opening of
moana you'll notice that he uses his
trusty hook to land his raft just a few
seconds later the hook has vanished we
all know maui's hook is magic but we
didn't know it could also vanish on its
own you see my hook no magic hook no
magic power in the climactic scene
entangled where flynn cuts off
rapunzel's hair there's a shot that
shows his hands are in shackles although
in a close-up shot where flynn touches
rapunzel's hair the shackles don't seem
to be on him anymore so either flynn is
the houdini of the kingdom or this was
another case of classic disney goof
look at me look at me i'm right here
don't go stay with me eugene flower
gleam and glow
towards the climax of frozen two as anna
orders the rock giants to throw boulders
at the dam they hurl rocks that damage
the middle section as well as another
corner on the opposite end anna should
be trapped yet we see a shot of anna
running across the section that was
previously damaged as if nothing
happened to it maybe this means anna has
some powers of her own i did it all
without powers so you know i'm coming
after maui is unwillingly transformed
into a half-man half-shark there appears
to be nothing lying in front of him in
the sand yet just a few seconds later a
small rock suddenly is shown lying in
front of maui's feet which he proceeds
to kick it's not cursed
shark head once the villainous king
candy or turbo is defeated at the end of
wreck-it ralph the sugar rush game
appears to reset back to before the
jaded arcade character's invasion well
almost everything the popcorn box
bleachers at the start and finish line
of the racetrack still appear to have
the initials kc on them all right to be
continued
as hank and dory make their way through
the marine park using a stroller they
bump into a little girl wearing a
striped shirt in the next shot we see
the distraught young girl her shirt has
changed from striped to pink maybe her
mom brought her a spare shirt i know
that why do i know that
both incredibles films take place in an
alternate version of the early 60s which
can be seen in the newspapers that the
characters read in the films despite the
setting one of the newspapers in mr
incredible's office has the date
september 16 2002 printed on it so
either the super strong hero has been
time traveling or the folks at pixar
forgot to change the date must have
happened a long time ago in the scene in
pocahontas where nakoma walks with
pocahontas to see the captured john
smith they appear to be holding hands
yet their shadows don't actually portray
that and make it seem like they're
walking separately pocahontas wants to
look into the eyes of the man who killed
kokomo
in the scene where lilo and nani visit
the animal shelter a telephone can be
seen at the front desk as nani prepares
to sign stitch's adoption papers but in
the next shot the phone appears to be
missing entirely could this be a case of
alien technology gonomak or is this just
a simple mistake that was overlooked
that's up to you to decide
why don't you run
it's entirely common for an animal's eye
color to change over time but not quite
like this nala's eye color changes seem
to shift quite quickly one moment they
appear to be bright green and the next
they are clearly blue and the pattern
continues maybe it's something in the
water yes we do
you're the king oh we've been through
this i'm not the king scar is the human
world may be strange to ariel who's
lived all her life under the sea but it
shouldn't be so mysterious to our eyes
as ariel jumps into bed you can see that
there's no blankets but in the next shot
in the same night you can see that ariel
has wrapped herself up in blankets how
did those get there
you are hopeless child
you know that
while tarzan is rated g it definitely
doesn't shy away from showing some tense
jungle action
as the titular hero faces off against
sabor the leopard gives the king of the
jungle some noticeable bright red
scratches in the midst of the battle yet
when tarzan emerges victorious from the
battle there's no scratches to be found
on his body maybe the ape man has some
superpowers of his own what was that
when the mechanical boy next door sid
has to delay his rocket launch of buzz
lightyear because of a thunderstorm he
sets his alarm clock to 8 25 am however
the next morning instead of going off at
8 25 sid's alarm clock goes off 85
minutes earlier at 7 am that clock
definitely isn't doing buzz and woody
any favors
the animation team behind this disney
classic had their work cut out for them
which meant that there were a couple of
minor slip ups along the way as pongo
pulls roger towards anita and perdita
you can see that roger's hat has been
left behind at the bench with roger
having no time to pick it up however the
hat is placed perfectly back on roger's
head just a few moments later as he
approaches anita
oh oh dear
really oh good heavens of all them
there's a lot that goes into making your
favorite disney flicks yes pay attention
so it is inevitable that there's going
to be at least a couple of mistakes that
fall through the cracks while they may
have seemed burdensome to the animators
at first it's certainly become fun for
fans to spot the goofs do you have a
favorite hidden mistake in a disney
movie